Its the day of the fight
August 25th , KSI vs Logan
Deji vs Jake
the fight  is in a couple of hours
Logan Paul and Jake made a video explaining how you can watch it.
By paying with credit card.
Were gonna blur that cuz f*** ya'll
Dude, he blurred his card better than he blurred the body
Now if your'e looking to see the fight in this video, i've got bad news for ya.
Just take it from Jake himself.
And if you think you're gonna be able to watch it for free afterwards,
You're WRONG because there's people stripping down all of the content that everyone else uploads.
So the only way you're gonna be able to see the fight is if you can get the pay-per-view.
don't worry, I will still show the outcome at the end of this video
I know everyones dying to know who wins
it's not like it doesn't matter..
*pewds laughs*
I'll also give my prediction on who I think is gonna win
and who I want to win
BUT FIRST
let's review the Weight in.
It was yesterday. And if you thought the press conferences has been cringy
it was somehow they managed to make it even worse
they looked at all the press conferences and they said
"You know what? Not cringy enough!"
We need to up it way more
Alright everyone we ready?
*SHUT UP*
I'm the TrueGordie
and welcome to the KSI vs Logan Paul weigh in
*Takes a big sniff*
We're gonna start off..
For some reason raka raka was there
I don't know how that came in out of nowhere
next up to the stage. It's raka raka
*crowd claps*
YEAH!!!
LET'S GET IT!
*crowd laughs*
Why
Oh God
It's a bit awkward
yes, it is it is a bit awkward, can we cut this please
the guard is loving it at least I'm glad he's having a good time
And then for some reason he's fighting scarce
why have I not heard about this
Next to the stage it's scarce
So scarce is here. Why is he not fighting?
No, that would actually make it the biggest event on internet history
This is a family friendly show all right.
UGH
He's on the scales
yikes
Weighing in at
79 kilograms
Scarce, you know, you're allowed to breathe that
Breathe out please you could die
Im concerned
Then they have the most awkward stare off that has ever been done
Probably ever
Raka put on his clothes
Scares is like, I don't know
Should I put on a shirt or something
then he decides to keep it up
anyone else like that.
Yes. I didn't know whether we're gonna kiss or punch each other.
You could have gone either way
youre right, man. I can't wait for that fight.
That should be pretty good
you can tell they clearly hate each other
so much drama, so much tension.
Let's get to the point
Jake came out about 10 minutes later and damn
Jake look's ripped He really bulked up man.
Whoa, look at that
I promise I know it's gonna be a good fight now.
Okay. Now I'm excited. This is gonna be epic.
No, just kidding
after about five minutes for Jake Paul to take off his bling
by five other guys
we finally get on the scale
any any moment
on the scales Jake Paul
then Jake Paul makes a statement about the fight.
It's gonna be a first round knockout
Its not gonna be you
its not bloody hell gonna be you, is it jakey?
All right, next up the Deji! My man.
He's been training hard
That's the number one thing about Deji.
He's been like.
I'm working hard. Okay, doesn't matter that I lost my trainer.
Okay. I'm working hard
I'm training hard and you know Deji  looks a little goofy
but once he takes it off to the glasses
Now, we get to see how hard he's trained.
Finally. He's gonna look hard
I know it for sure (right)
He is DEEEEEEJJJIIIIIIII
stepping onto the scale.
oh no
he's trained
Oh No
Deji Oh No
What have you been doing Deji
He hasn't been training?
hes been drinking b e e r s
You know, I thought well at least you know
even if you lose the fight
At least by the end of it, you'll be ripped.
I know it's not about
looking ripped.
I know it's about the kills. I'm just joking.
It's a joke, then Deji makes his statement, Deji
always has the best statement.
He's always got the smartest things to say.
that's why I like Deji.
For those three minute rounds. That's gonna be the tough part
you trained hard. Have you trained hard Deji is the question.
What is he gonna say?
we were meant to have a faceoff now. I didn't want one
because he's too scared to come at me.
How does that make any sense. How doesn't make any sense, right?
Okay. So
We're meant to do a face of-
this doesn't make any sense. Like we're supposed to fight and stuff like okay
how does that
nothing this doesn't make any sense where I am.
I-I don't understand that
yeah, well, he's delusional
Pake Jaul is delusional. I'm gonna show him augus- it's tomorrow! Tomorrow..
*Pewdiepie starts laughing*
*Claps*
august 2-. It's tomorrow!?
I just realized that's tomorrow,
holy heck, I don't believe it
the fight is tomorrow
great response to the question
Deji thank you very much as always! The moment
we've all have been waiting for, Logan Paul vs KSI
Logan the maverick paaaaauuuulll
*crowd claps*
let's go change
*More clapping* (and booing)
LeT's gO lOgaN!
*pewds laughs*
LET'S GO LOGANNN
the pitch gets a little higher once Logan gets on stage
LeT's gO lOgaN!
LET'S GO LOGAN
LOGAN!!
Logan Logaaann
I love you Logan!!
Next up KSI comes out finally
The reigning and defending oh no. Oh no, he did not
That is Logan Paul's girlfriend. Oh my god
He's had absolute mad lad
This thing this whole thing is just a clown show
Oh My god, but my favorite thing out of this whole waiting.
It's the face up
Logan posed a great meme.
He's like Oh your breath is really bad.
Hey, look what I got some gum
alright, let's it's really bad here you go Ksi and he takes it
Chew dat! Chew dat! Chew dat!
Hope that was a piece of cyanide.
No, I don't that was a joke.
Why did he take it?
KSI mysteriously dies before the fight.
Now, we know why why
Did he think it's so weird?
so strange
I'm so confused.
This whole thing is so weird now for me
The fight is in a couple hours
has probably already happened when you're watching this video
I wanted to give my thoughts before I see it
who my honest predictions is. I don't know the outcome
I really really want Deji to win
just purely from the fact that from a boxing fight.
The winner will be comedyshortsgamer
Everybody
Cuz that's his YouTube channel name comedyshortsgamer
Check out the win.
I hope Deji is going to win just because he's the underdog
and I
Think Jake can handle losing better than Deji.
Does that make any sense?
However, I think Jake is going to win it
We'll see afterwards if I was right.
When it comes to Logan and KSI uh same thing with KSI
I've always thought he was an idiot
But watching some of the podcasts that he's done without all the drama
without all the crazy screaming at each other
I realized he's not an idiot.
He's a level-headed dude, and I really- I do respect him
I do hope he wins purely on the fact that he's-
he wants to do boxing, right?
So if he loses against Logan he can't really do that
He's really the only one that got something to lose here Logan has nothing to lose essentially
I think he's the one that's gonna come out strongest throughout this whole thing because of it
I probably ripped into Logan more than any other youtuber
But I actually do hope he does as well. I do hope this will be his way
To move forward. I mean, he's already apologized.
What else can he do at this point?
Like I don't think anyone actually cares still.
Uh who's gonna win between KSI and Logan
It's so good cause I don't know
like I don't know. I think Logan's gonna win it
I think both the paul brothers gonna take it
and then I think it's gonna be a rematch
But that's just what I think place your bets
if you don't know in the comments right now,
I'll be back in a few hours which will be in a second
and uhh
We'll see how it went.
Oh boy. Here we go.
Here's the live footage of the fight
I got special permission to show it.
Don't worry guys. This video won't get strike because of it
Now if you watch the fight, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry. You went through that.
That was awful. Okay
I want my money back
the whole chat is this going refund?
Everyone
*pewds laughs*
Basically
KSI vs Logan got a draw of course and
KSI just goes whoa. Let's do that again
That was fun. No, it wasn't fun. Okay, you guys made millions
Congratulations, but fool me once.
Okay, fool me twice. No, Thank you
Uhh
Jake won against Deji as I expected too bad though.
It was a good fight. Good job both ya
scarce lost against Rucka Rucka and
Yeah, that's it. I-I won't I how can I refund does it work?